60 عاما عمرو علاقات السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه جمعتهما توافقات عده في الكثير
من الجوانب السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه في منذ نشاتها في العام
1962 كان للبلدين محطات مهمه اقتصاديا
وتجاريا حيث شهدت العلاقات المشتركه منذ
بدايتها اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم اسهم في
جعل السعوديه من اوائل الشركاء التجاريين
لكوريا الجنوبيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
حيث كان من اهمها تاسيس اللجنه السعوديه
الكوريه المشتركه فيما شكل اطلاق رؤيه
السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 في العام 2017
نقطه تحول مهمه لتاسيس مرحله الشراكه اكبر
في قطاعات الاستراتيجيه منها النقل
والطاقه والاتصالات حيث تستهدف كوريا
الجنوبيه من خلالها ان تكون من ابرز
الشركاء المساهمين في تحقيق رؤيه السعوديه
20 30
في العام 20 21 بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري
بين السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه نحو 26
مليار دولار في مسجل الميزان التجاري
فائضا لصالح السعوديه بقيمه 19 مليار
دولار
وعلى الصعيد الاستثمارات تعمل شركه سعوديه
مختلفه في السوق الكوريه من ابرزها
استثمار والمقو السعوديه حيث تعمل من
خلالها اربعه مشاريع وشركتين تتجاوز
قيمتها الخمس مليارات دولار وايضا سابق
تعمل بحجم استثمارات بلغ مليار دولار
وفي الجهه المقابله بلغ عدد الاستثمارات
الكوريه في السعوديه
132 استثمارا باجمالي راس المال يتجاوز
ثلاث مليارات في قطاعات منها التعدين
والكهرباء والغاز
زياره ولي العهد السعودي
مع شركات كوريه والسعوديه في مختلف
المجالات مع توقعاتنا بجذب المزيد من
الاستثمارات الكوريه الى المملكه ميسون
ويهد العربيه سول كوريا الجنوبيه